Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in this
video I'm revealing all the super-cool easter eggs
and details hidden in We Can Be Heroes, including
a secret cameo from the real original Sharkboy.
Just before we begin, many thanks to the
sponsor of this video, Raid Shadow Legends.
Obviously, spoilers ahead, so take care.
When it comes to breakfast time, Missy is
a fan of Great White Bites cereal,
as Max was in the original movie.
In fact, you can see several
packs of the shark-inspired
cereal in the Moreno family's kitchen.
After they're captured by the aliens,
the Heroics can't stop bickering
and fighting amongst themselves.
"Why don't you cheer us up by singing one
of those songs you sing so well, Sharkboy?"
Here Miracle Guy is mocking Sharkboy
about the lullaby he sang in the first
film to help Max fall asleep so he could
dream a solution to their problems.
"Close your eyes, shut your mouth.
Dream a dream and get us out."
Although Sharkboy's song was initially successful,
it actually ended up giving Max nightmares!
While the original Lavagirl, Taylor Dooley, is
back to play the adult version of her character,
Taylor Lautner doesn't return as Sharkboy.
Instead adult Sharkboy's a non-speaking
character played by a mask-wearing JJ
Dashnaw, who was the Stunt Co-ordinator
for both the sequel and the first film.
There are some awesome easter eggs to the
original movie in Missy's bedroom.
Look carefully at her bedside table
and in the corner you'll spot the first of two
children's novels that were co-written by the
film's director Robert Rodriguez and published
around the time of the movie's release in 2005.
There's The Day Dreamer which tells the film's
story from Lavagirl and Sharkboy's point of view.
And I suspect the book below
that is Return to Planet Drool,
the second in the Sharkboy and Lavagirl series.
Also on Missy's nightstand is her Heroics-themed
alarm clock, and a fun detail here is
that while the other superheroes are
doing the hard work of holding up the clock,
Miracle Guy is just standing there, posing.
Which given that he stops to take a photo during
the alien invasion at the start of the movie,
seems like a perfect reflection of reality!
"Just a quick selfie for my
socials while I stop this thing."
In the sequel, Missy's bedroom is space-themed,
with planets, stars, and moons on her bedhead
and walls, and constellations on this fabric;
which is just like in the first film where Max's
bedroom also had a cosmic theme, with mobiles of
the solar system, moons, stars and galaxies on the
walls, and stickers of planets on his bed frame.
And both lead characters also
wear space-themed pyjamas.
Max has planets on his, while Missy
has stars on hers and she also has
stars on the black trousers she
wears throughout the film.
After sneaking on board an extra-terrestrial
supply ship, Missy and her super-powered
friends desperately try to get away
from the aliens about to attack them:
The fact it's more difficult to fly this ship than
simply pressing the 'green for go' button is a
send-up of the scene in the original movie where
hitting the green 'Go' button was all Max had to
do to blast off in his shark-shaped rocket.
"So, how do you fly it?"
"You don't know?"
"That's sort of been the whole problem!"
"You press go."
Also when Guppy
puts on a pair of blue sunglasses
during the kids' training session,
I couldn't help but think of her father's blue
3D shark-shaped glasses in the previous movie!
Vivien Blair who plays Guppy was actually
given the glasses as it was so bright filming
outside that she couldn't stop squinting;
but then the filmmakers decided she looked so
cool that they made them part of her character's
costume whenever she went into a shark frenzy!
"Guppy, listen to me.
Shark frenzy."
And that behaviour is another thing she has in
common with her dad!
"Shark frenzy!"
All of Ojo's tablet pictures were
actually drawn on set during the filming
of those scenes by Rhiannon Rodriguez,
daughter of director Robert Rodriguez.
As for the squiggle monsters, the filmmakers
wanted them to look like a child had created
them with her own pen as they wanted
to illustrate the idea that "the pen
is always mightier than the sword".
The fact that Ojo's drawings come to
life also reminds me of how the imaginary
worlds and superheroes Max doodles and
writes about in his dream journal also
come to life in the first movie.
When Guppy demonstrates her powers for Missy,
the pint-sized superhero takes a gulp of water,
then spits out a liquid shark,
which she moves into a position
that's a clear hat-tip to the theatrical poster
for the 1975 shark-infested blockbuster, Jaws.
Later in the film, as Slo-mo desperately tries
to outrun the aliens chasing him, A Capella
starts singing the iconic theme to the
Oscar-winning movie Chariots of Fire,
whose tale of British athletes vying
for the 1924 Olympics famously featured
several slow-mo running sequences set to
composer Vangelis' legendary score.
By the way, in order to give A Capella's
voice an extra-otherworldly effect,
"Adios."
when she sings the higher notes,
the filmmakers blended together the voice of
actress Lotus Blossom who plays A Capella with
the voice of American Idol singer Haley
Reinhart who plays her mother Mrs Vox.
Sharkboy and Lavagirl's daughter Guppy is
named after a type of small tropical fish,
which is perfect for her character as she's
both little and has water-related powers.
Continuing the aquatic theme, on her
t-shirt, there's a picture of a fish.
And her clothes and water bottle are blue, pink,
and purple, which are the colours of her parents.
As for the rainbow on Guppy's necklace, that's
a subtle symbol at the start of the film that
she and her fellow super-kids are humanity's
hope for a better world, which is exactly what
Ojo tells them at the end of the movie.
While Missy's starry clothing is a shout-out
to the first movie, it also reflects the fact
she's the real star of the new team, as without
her inspiring them to work together, they'd be
in the same mess as their bickering parents.
But Missy's not only at the heart
of the new Heroics, she's also a
character with a lot of heart,
which could be why the film's
costume designer chose to put some
subtle little hearts on her outfit,
from her T-shirt to her heart-shaped necklace.
Like many of the other kids whose clothing
signals their powers, Wheels has a W-style
symbol on his shirt, which suitably enough
also looks a little like jagged skid marks.
Taylor Lautner may have skipped the sequel, but
two of the other original Sharkboys do return.
Look out for the pilot of the helicopter during
the Heroics' big battle scene:
"You ok, Sharkboy?"
That pilot is Racer Rodriguez who played
a young Sharkboy in the previous film.
In fact, Racer truly is the original Sharkboy
because as a 7-year-old child he actually
created the character of Sharkboy when he
playing a game of fish vs shark with his dad,
Robert Rodriguez, in the family pool.
And while Racer also co-produced the new
sequel, his brother Rebel, who played the
five-year-old Sharkboy in the first movie,
wrote the music for the new sequel!
And there's a Rodriguez family in-joke
at the end of the film.
The film's alien spaceship
sets were in fact designed by Rogue
Rodriguez, another of the director's kids.
By the way, I've got another video
that reveals all the clues that
pointed to the movie's big twist.
There'll be a link to that at the end
of this video and in the description below.
Another Rodriguez sibling, Rhiannon, is the voice
of Missy's alarm clock at the start of the movie,
singing 'Wake Up Sleepyhead' in a little shout-out
to Max's rocket alarm in the first
film which displays the words 'Wake Up,
Max!' when the alarm goes off.
♪ Wake up, sleepyhead♪
♪ Wake up..♪
Rhiannon was also the
inspiration for the film's lead character whose
name Missy is actually Rhiannon's nick-name
and whose initials were intended to reflect
the alliteration in Rhiannon's name too.
And, of course, that also fits very nicely
with the world of comic-book superheroes,
especially Marvel ones, whose names
often rely on alliteration.
And if you're looking for more super-powered fun
to entertain yourself over the holidays and new
year, you should check out Raid: Shadow Legends.
It's an epic fantasy gaming experience with
badass champions, tough bosses and millions of
other players you can pit yourself against.
Set amid an epic struggle that's raged for
thousands of years, you'll fight noble kings
and dark wizards, uncover prophecies, curses,
betrayals, and meet scores of warring factions.
Use the links below to download
Raid to your mobile phone or PC.
One of the best things about Raid is the 16
awesome factions which include Lizardmen,
Banner Lords, Undead Hordes and many more.
And each faction has its own set of
unique champions that you can collect.
I'm a fan of the Dwarves and High Elves
factions as they have some awesome champions
such as the legendary Arbiter, a
servant of the Goddess of Light.
Among the dwarvish champions I like
Beardal Fellhammer who has an awesome
protection ability that was bestowed
on him by Fey spirits of the forest.
His paranoia skill also gives him great
counter-attack abilities and stamina, making
him an amazing champion for farming campaigns.
And just in time for the holidays and New Year,
Raid have launched their biggest
ever update with the Doom Tower.
It's a giant tower with 120 floors, a
bunch of secret challenge rooms, and 12
incredible new bosses to take on.
On top of that, they're releasing
14 badass new champions and a ton
of holiday events and tournaments.
It's a perfect moment to start
playing and here's the best part:
if you sign up today you'll get a stack of free
goodies and a super-special Champion called
Bulwark to get you started in the Doom Tower.
He's a super-strong dwarf who'll wear down
the enemy with his discipline and
incredibly tough defensive skills,
keeping you in the game much longer.
So, to get a huge head start in Raid, hit
the link in the description below; and if you're a
new player, you'll get your Void Champion Bulwark,
an XP booster, Energy Refills, and an
Ancient Shard all completely free.
After you've installed the game, you'll find all
of these rewards and treasure in your inbox here.
Don't forget, you can only get these
bonuses by clicking on the links below!
The offer runs for the next 30 days only, so don't
delay and install Raid Shadow Legends today!
Now, what do you think about
the Sharkboy & Lavagirl sequel?
And did you notice any other
cool details in the film?
Let me know in the comments.
Tap left to find out all the hidden clues
you missed to the movie's big twist ending!
Or tap right for something
else you're sure to like.
And if you enjoyed this video, a
thumbs-up is hugely appreciated!
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!